i want to talk to you about how i
learned japanese
this is steve kaufman again if you enjoy
my videos please subscribe click on the
bell for notifications
so
you know how did it come about that i
learned japanese japanese ended up being
very influential
in my life my
social life my professional career
and yet you know back in 1968 i was sent
to hong kong
by the canadian government to learn
mandarin chinese
so how did i end up with japanese being
such a dominant language in my life
so i thought i would go over that and go
over with you some of the sort of
things that helped me learn japanese
and
more than any book or anything as i sort
of reflect back on it now it was my
attitude
and of course the amount of time that i
was prepared to spend on learning
japanese
so
68 i go to hong kong i spent a year
learning chinese
and then the idea was that i would be
working in the
canadian high commission in hong kong
using my chinese
unfortunately
there developed a sort of a
conflict a personality conflict or
whatever
with my immediate boss at the high
commission
and the idea was that
canada would open up a an embassy in
beijing
and i would be working for this person
it would be a very isolated posting
he and i didn't get along
so i announced to
the canadian trade commissioner service
that i refused to go to beijing to work
under this person in an isolated post
life would be held for two and a half
years i said on the other hand since the
government had paid for me essentially
to learn chinese which i had done in
in uh you know
quick time in in
a year whereas normally two years was
sort of the allotted time to learn
chinese
i said i will if you assign me to japan
i will learn japanese on my own won't
cost you a penny and you will have at
least got some return on your investment
which looking back on it is is kind of
um almost a foolhardy thing for me to do
but i was not prepared to go and spend
two years
in an isolated post with someone with
whom i had very strong personality
conflicts
and in their wisdom the trade
commissioner service agreed
so i then started buying books in hong
kong on japanese
and i still remember that one of the
first things i learned
was
how does how you how you say
how do you do when you meet someone for
the first time and the expression was
all right
i learned that i
sort of memorized it i have never used
that expression nobody uses nobody uses
that expression a completely useless
expression
it's an indication that much of what you
get in beginner books may not be all
that useful you have to
be prepared to
you don't necessarily eliminate it but
you learn it and forget it you don't
worry about it anything that's thrown at
me at any stage in my learning
it's not really important to me whether
i am able to hang on to it
in time i'll figure out whether i need
it or whether i don't now in the case of
omini kakarite taihenko and hisonjimas
not something that i ever needed
so while in hong kong because i had
friends amongst the various other
diplomats who were studying chinese i
had very good friends amongst the
people at the japanese consulate and one
of those people was
very fluent in
chinese
and
he wanted to learn english
so we would meet for lunch twice a week
at a very famous
dim sum place in hong kong the
look
hotel
and tuesday we would speak english and
thursday we would speak japanese i don't
know what i was able to say whatever i
was able to find in my book i would trot
it out it wasn't much of a conversation
but it was part of starting to
experience things japanese
so then in
i guess january of 71 we moved to japan
and i went to a school right under the
tokyo tower
called the nitoguri
nihongo gakko japanese school nito guri
sensei was a very charismatic man and
his message was kokoro to kokoro heart
to heart
and we would sit around
in this classroom five or six of us and
we would all try to mumble something in
japanese
and i did that for a month and then i
realized that this was largely a waste
of my time so i quit that
and i started doing a lot of reading i
let i read a lot in in this series by
naganuma which i mentioned before which
is all hiragana
because since i had the characters from
chinese i had to get used to the kana
and even though
compared to chinese characters hiragana
is easy to learn there's only whatever
it is 50 symbols
never underestimate how difficult it is
to get used to a new writing system even
though theoretically you know what the
symbols represent before your brain gets
used to absorbing
you know
messages information with that writing
system takes a long long time so i read
lots and i listened to lots
and
continued to scour the bookstores for
reading material
wherever possible with cassette tapes
much more difficult at that time to find
such material but whatever i could find
i consumed
i was lucky enough that
at the canadian embassy where i was
working i had an assistant commercial
officer as they were known these are
locally engaged staff who worked with
the trade commissioners who had the
contacts who would accompany you to
visits and his name was nick yazaki and
he was extremely long-winded and
extremely patient and he would speak to
me and he would say everything four or
five times and i would listen to him and
i would imitate his the way he droned on
and repeated things but when you're
learning a language if you are lucky
enough to have someone to talk to who is
a you know long of wind and repeats
things that's extremely helpful
and with nick we would go and visit
you know potential you know
contacts people who wanted to buy
canadian products uh first two years i
was promoting food products in the
second two years of the four years i was
promoting forest products
and we would visit with japanese
contacts and um
i would kind of hang in there but you
know and i try to say something and i
pretend that i understood it and i think
this was the other attitude that i had
it never bothered me that i for the
longest time didn't understand a hundred
percent i understand 30 40 50 but i'd be
in there nodding part of the deal after
the meeting i'd asked nick what exactly
did they say i maybe i said something
that was totally irrelevant it never
really bothered me
i was in a japanese environment i was
being exposed to the language i was
picking up on things
and but it does take a long time and i
can remember that even after years of
living in japan the only television
programs that i could understand were
baseball
and sumo
because there's you know
the dialogue is relatively limited
you're seeing what's happening
so that was kind of what i would watch
it took me a long time before i could
understand
you know
drama you know soap operas or sword
movies or slash movies or any of that
stuff
uh it just takes a long time but i was
in a hurry i certainly didn't want to
write any exam in japanese i just wanted
to use it
to the extent that i could use it
and and where my japanese really took
off was when i
left the embassy and i started working
on my own so now i didn't have a nick
yazaki
i had to basically you know handle these
relationships by myself
and
there were times and i had japanese
people working with me
and we'd be in the car driving around
the kansai for hours in traffic and just
talking talking talking talking about
lumber i'm talking about and of course
the japanese web business is quite
fascinating and i had to learn about how
they cut the trees the logs and how they
cut for different grade for different
grain for different qualities the
different
you know idiosyncrasies of wood that
they didn't like or did like and we
could talk forever about wood mostly we
just talked about wood but we talked for
hours
and i also had a customer but we didn't
only talk but i had a customer when i
was working for a major again canadian
forest products export company i had a
customer in nagoya we were also selling
newsprint
and the chunichi shimbun in nagoya which
is the major newsprint in the newspaper
in aguero they had a purchasing manager
and i had to go and and be nice to him
so that they would continue buying our
paper
and i would go down there once a month
and we would sit in a japanese
restaurant sit on the floor and consume
a bottle of whiskey and discuss
philosophy so i had to be up on subjects
related to philosophy we didn't talk
about the price of newsprint we didn't
talk about anything related to business
we talked about philosophy which was a
lot of fun
and i mean i can't remember all the
different things but my basic attitude
was one of just you know roll with the
punches um
and and i would go and find readers with
glossaries
and and for the longest time when i saw
a chinese character i would pronounce it
to myself in chinese
and
very often not know how that was
pronounced in japanese i i they were
like i would hear it and i knew what it
meant but i didn't necessarily relate
that character to any particular
pronunciation so i would read in
hiragana pronounce it in chinese
continue reading in hiragana and acquire
this vocabulary now this has all be
become much easier today
because we have text-to-speech we can
look up words and dictionaries we can we
have like that link we have furigana the
little hiragana guys on top of the
characters it's just so much easier it's
unbelievably
much easier even though
you know link is not perfect because the
word splitting algorithm
doesn't quite work as well as we would
like and we're looking at ways to make
it better but it's still so much easier
to learn today than it was back in those
days so
uh and and i should say amongst the
various sources that i would listen to
when i got into my car in tokyo in
august when it was like 36 degrees and
the sun has been beating down on my car
and i get in there and the steering
wheel is just like
scalding hot and i would put on my showa
no kiroku the history of the showa era
which i must have listened to 20 30
times
so it's all i think my
immersion in japanese was one of i
wanted to explore
i wanted to experience the language i'd
say what i thought i was able to say
sometimes you get it wrong didn't bother
me i listened to what people were saying
to me
and basically relied on my brain to
gradually start saying more and more
things correctly i never really focused
in on the grammar grammar rules
rules about you know when to use which
polite form
none of that i just basically allowed
the language to come to me and trusted
that my brain would pick up on the
patterns of the language
and today my japanese is as it is it's
not perfect uh i don't i haven't tried
to zoom in on any particular you know
aspects of either polite language or
pitch accent or any of these other
things i communicate i understand
i'm happy
it serves my purposes
and i think people
uh are quite comfortable communicating
with me in japanese and you can watch
two of my videos in japanese here just
to give you a bit of the flavor of my
japanese as it is right now which
reminds me i just wanted to say one more
thing learning other languages
and having an absence from japanese has
improved my japanese in other words the
fact of learning other languages and
particularly the 10 languages i've
learned since the age of 60 including
russian including you know
korean ukrainian and now struggling with
arabic and persian all of that is good
for the brain and actually improves my
japanese although if i haven't spoken
for a while i'm initially quite rusty
but then ultimately i become better so
there you have it uh
a brief discussion of how i learned
japanese i hope that's helpful